hey this is GameSpot's review of sniper
ghost Warrior 3 I'm Justin hey wolde
filling in for our author Richard
wiggling previous entries in the sniper
ghost Warrior series have been
justifiably criticized for their
stifling linearity but it appears that
polish developer CI games has seen the
error of its ways and changed course for
sniper ghost Warrior 3 the latest game
in the series ditches the restrictive
nosov its predecessors by shifting the
action to the gritty open-world of a
separatist controlled Georgia with an
increase in scale and the flexibility
inherent therein it's a positive
direction for the skull splitting series
Albion one that's still frequently
disrupted by unmistakable flaws the
jagged cliffs and dense forests of the
Georgian wilderness are notable for
their expansiveness yet the muted color
palette lackluster lighting and some
muddy low quality textures do little to
inspire all conceptually this is also an
open world without a clear defined
purpose with little in the way of
interesting locales to entice
exploration it's also a particularly
barren world pockets of civilian life do
their best to present the illusion of a
living breathing society but their
nonplussed reactions to a burly Marine
barging into their houses aren't exactly
believable for as disappointing as this
is it matters little once you've reached
the whereabouts of your active mission
each one is generally contained within a
single sizeable location whether that's
a decrepit block of apartments or a busy
airfield objectives are refreshingly
varied and there are often optional
tasks to complete if you're up for say
retrieving a downed drone or completing
the active missions with no alerts ghost
Warrior 3 is at its best
however when simulating the methodical
precision of being an elite marksman
there's a rhythm to the planning and
execution that goes into these missions
that involve stalking tagging enemies
finding a vantage point and adjusting
your equipment ever so slightly to
account for the environmental conditions
while this sounds short and sweet
missions can take upwards of 20 minutes
to complete if you're willing to take
your time sniping is all about being
cautious and taking a
measured approach and you're rewarded
for your patience with some immensely
satisfying kill shots for first-person
shooters it offers a unique approach
that sets ghost warrior 3 apart from its
history on it contemporaries sniping is
the winning card in its deck and yet CI
games regularly play as other hands to
the game's detriment completing actions
in each group sniping for sniper
performing close quarters stealth kills
for ghosts and going all guns blazing
for warrior net u XP that can be spent
on some humdrum upgrades in each like
Auto looting bodies or increasing the
effect of health items it's not the most
exciting system but the added emphasis
on different playstyles makes them all
viable options the ability to react to
an ever-changing situation and
completely alter your approach adds a
sense of variety to each mission sure
this stealth is incredibly simplistic
and open gun fights are ponderous but is
Minu compliments to the sniping they
serve a functional purpose where this
falters is when these Styles take center
stage there are missions where your
sniper rifle is taken out of your hands
and others where the tight confines of
the level render your sharpshooter too
unwieldy to seriously consider these
missions dilute the game's strengths and
put it on a playing field with the likes
of Call of Duty and Battlefield where it
does not compare favorably
similarly irritating are the glitches
and rough edges peppered throughout in
the PlayStation 4 version I had enemies
tipos in front of me disappear in the
middle of a stealth takedown and
repopulate before my eyes inside what I
thought was an empty outpost the game
also crashed on four separate occasions
whenever you boot up the game or change
regions it takes almost 5 minutes to
load which is excruciatingly ly slow the
frame rate is also consistently shoddy
whether you're simply walking or popping
in and out of your sniper scope
sometimes sounds don't play and poppin
is a constant eyesore sniper ghost
Warrior 3 feels like a b-tier
budget-priced game even the predictable
profanity-laden story is reminiscent of
the type of gritty b-movie
Steven Seagal is no you Phil you to beat
yourself up all the boy pay yourself on
a guitar there certainly merit to its
accomplished sniping mechanics
especially human emissions hone in on
the planning and precise execution that
makes playing as a sharpshooter so
thrilling yet it falters whenever it
veers away from its strengths and the
plethora of nagging glitches and
technical problems are a persistent
nuisance that makes sniper ghost Warrior
3 difficult to recommend
[Music]